Meet C&T
A partner Company of Udacity
Business are transforming.
They must be faster.
The digital world is out there.
And CI&T's mission is exactly this,
to help companies transform.
And to transform, they must innovate.
They need to change business models,
change the way they do things,
and software is the essential part of it.
CI&T has been in the market for 22 years.
It's a global and
international Brazilian company.
For 22 years.
We have over 30% growth year over year.
And 2017 will be no different.
We have positions opened,
we have clients
expanding their contracts with us.
And we are very lucky to
get to work in the high-tech market,
providing innovative
solutions for CI&T's customers.
We have multidisciplinary teams,
because we're not only
focused in building software,
we want to deliver the
greatest value to our customers,
who will deliver the
greatest value to their customers.
So the team starts
with a Developer, a Tester,
going to an Architect, a Team Leader,
a Project Manager, a Senior Manager,
an Interface Designer, a Digital Strategist,
and sometimes even Marketing personnel,
who are going to help us
understand how to launch
a project like this on the market.
Another cool thing is
that we offer Y career plans.
So, like...you can...
up to a certain point in their career,
everyone goes on the same journey.
Then, you can choose
if you want to lean towards management
or more towards the technical area.
And that's cool because
people are not pulled into management
if they don't want to.
We look for people with a CI&T posture,
and we want to build an environment
that makes these postures prevail.
We talk a lot about diversity,
about autonomy, awareness, flexibility,
and I believe this is reflected
in how people act, you know?
CI&T is a Company
in which we dream of working.
But here, the...
whole environment
is projected in a way,
so that you feel
comfortable working.
So, there are even
spaces for us to relax,
for us to think, to study...
We've changed a lot
our recruiting process
and our hiring process.
And since late 2003
they are totally
focused on experiences,
on cases, on the day to day,
on how it feels to work at CI&T.
So we've already
held several hackathons,
really hands-on,
to show our team work,
how to get by when you face a problem.
It's not a test,
it's not a very simple assessment.
It's our day to day at work.
CI&T expects a lot
from our partnership with Udacity,
because we're always looking for
the most appropriate people for our staff.
And we look for people where they are,
and some of them
are definitely at Udacity.
Udacity manages to empower people
with some of the technologies we need,
some of the technical abilities we need.
CI&T has lots of opportunities
in the software development area
for multiple technologies.
Especially Java, iOS, Android,
people very specialized in Analytics and Big Data.
So, it seems to be far away from our reality,
but it's already here,
and we're looking for these people,
so that they can join CI&T.
Sign up for a Nanodegree
and speed up your career.